in 2019 this new BMW marked the start of
a new production in a car plant in
Western Russia
today it is Chinese cars coming off the
assembly line the factory produced tens
of thousands of vehicles including four
trucks German BMWs and South Korean
Hyundais every year until Russia's
invasion of Ukraine as International
sanctions prompted foreign automakers to
leave the country Chinese Brands filled
the void making billions of dollars car
makers who have been struggling in the
domestic Market in China they're finding
an opportunistic moment when it comes to
the Russian Market here's how Chinese
car makers are profiting from the
Western corporate Exodus and what it
means for Russia's Auto markets
car making is one of Russia's main
industries it employs some 300 000
people directly and produced vehicles in
Parts worth about 42 billion dollars in
2020. the first Renault created for the
Russian Market foreign automakers opened
factories and partnered with local
Brands pushing Russia into the ranks of
the world's top car producers and
Russians eagerly embraced foreign cars
with Japanese Korean and European Brands
dominating the market for years
but moscow's invasion of Ukraine hit the
industry hard
Western sanctions cut off Russia's
access to global Supply chains for
essential Parts such as computer chips
prompting many foreign Brands to Halt
production or withdraw from the country
soaring inflation and uncertainty
contributed to a dramatic drop in car
sales in the country last year
but assembly lines didn't stay idle for
long demand started to pick up as
Chinese Brands stepped in car
dealerships across Russia started
reopening under new brands for example
this showroom outside Moscow changed
from Nissan to kaii from China
Russian buyers became more familiar with
Chinese cars Chinese SUVs have even been
spotted in the kremlin's motorcades by
mid-2023 the list of the 10 most popular
car brands in Russia looked very
different to before the war six of them
were Chinese this year Russia became the
number one buyer of Chinese vehicles
spending some six billion dollars in the
first four months of 2023 helping China
to become the world's largest Auto
exporter the exports to Russia got in
outside's importance especially for the
car makers who have struggled to Pivot
to a successful EV strategy within China
the sales of petroleum powered vehicles
have dropped so they now have some
excess capacity and Russia presents a
good opportunity for these car makers
but Russia's markets also poses
challenges as Chinese car brands become
more mature I think a lot of them are
seriously considering the prospect of
when they become the world's biggest
auto manufacturer and in the grand
scheme of things Russia may not be a big
consideration for them because of the
constraints in this market at present
Chinese automakers are also not immune
to the bad publicity that comes with
working in Russia in June in a symbolic
gesture Ukraine branded Chinese maker
Julie as a sponsor of War for continuing
operations in Russia companies like
Julie have multiple Brands and some of
these Brands trying to explore the
Western European market so if they make
a big push in Russia then it may cause
them other problems in terms of real
political risks because it may not be a
well-regarded in front of Western
European consumers
Chile declined to comment on the
challenges related to its operations in
Russia Russia's after door plants which
now produces Chinese Passenger cars
didn't respond to a request for comment
Chinese automaker's expansion into the
Russian Market highlights the ever
closer ties between Beijing and Moscow
at the moment the relationship appears
to be mutually beneficial however the
question is whether Chinese brands are
willing to keep taking the risks
associated with Russia and manage the
unpredictable nature of doing business
there in the long run